aquí tenemos una superficie dura plana
sin fricción arriba de ella tenemos un
bloque que no está acelerando en
dirección alguna se encuentra en reposo
sobre la superficie digamos que el peso
de este bloque es de 10 newtons pausa en
el vídeo y piensen en todas las fuerzas
que están actuando sobre este bloque
resolvamos esto juntos para hacerlo
vamos a dibujar lo que se conoce como
diagrama de cuerpo libre en donde se
dibujan todas las fuerzas que actúan
sobre el bloque se llama diagrama de
cuerpo libre porque nos enfocamos en un
cuerpo un objeto no dibujamos nada más
alrededor de este cuerpo excepto las
fuerzas que actúan sobre él existen dos
formas de dibujar un diagrama de cuerpo
libre una es esta dibujamos el bloque
recuerden que el peso del bloque es de
10 newtons el peso del objeto es la
fuerza de gravedad que está actuando
sobre ese objeto y cuya dirección es
hacia abajo dibujamos la fuerza de
gravedad actuando sobre la masa de este
objeto con dirección hacia abajo y una
magnitud de 10 newtons al dibujar un
diagrama de cuerpo libre es típico
dibujar todos los vectores iniciando en
el mismo punto
que es el centro del objeto en cuestión
ahora les pregunto es esta la única
fuerza actuando sobre este bloque si
ustedes piensan que sí entonces que le
pasaría al objeto en este caso estaría
acelerando hacia abajo pero al inicio
mencionamos que el bloque está en reposo
por lo que debe existir algo que está
contrarrestando esta fuerza y lo hay es
la fuerza normal de la superficie que
está actuando sobre el objeto la
superficie es lo que evita que el bloque
acelere hacia abajo dibujamos el vector
de la fuerza normal hacia arriba y con
la misma magnitud la magnitud de la
fuerza normal es igual a la magnitud de
la fuerza de gravedad también es igual a
10 newtons pero con dirección hacia
arriba aquí podemos ver que estas dos
fuerzas se equilibran por lo que no
tenemos una fuerza le está actuando
sobre esta dirección tampoco tenemos
fuerzas que estén actuando en la
dirección horizontal por eso es que no
tenemos una fuerza atleta actuando sobre
este objeto y por eso no se acelera otra
forma de dibujar un diagrama de cuerpo
libre es esta dibujamos el cuerpo que
nos interesa
los vectores involucrados afuera del
cuerpo aquí están los 10 minutos hacia
abajo y aquí dibujamos los 10 newtons
hacia arriba estas son las dos formas de
dibujar diagramas de cuerpo libre ahora
hagamos algo interesante con este bloque
lo dibujamos de nuevo aquí abajo
esta es la superficie plana y dura aquí
está el bloque de 10 newtons ahora vamos
a aplicarle una fuerza al bloque esta
fuerza tiene esta dirección y tiene una
magnitud de 20 newtons para poder
indicar la dirección digamos que aquí
hay un ángulo de 60 grados que llamamos
theta ahora cómo será el diagrama de
cuerpo libre quizá nos veamos tentados a
dibujar el diagrama como el de aquí
arriba y simplemente agregar el nuevo
vector fuerza así esto no estaría
necesariamente equivocado pero debemos
tener en mente esto como esta fuerza
está actuando con un ángulo
debemos descomponer la en sus
componentes horizontal y vertical una
parte de esta fuerza está actuando hacia
abajo así que tendremos una fuerza
normal más grande para contrarrestarlas
otra parte de esta fuerza está actuando
horizontalmente así que es necesario
descomponer esto para ver más claramente
lo que ocurre pues si dejamos esta
fuerza con el ángulo nos vamos a
confundir
así pues vamos a descomponer este vector
de fuerza azul en sus componentes
horizontal y vertical para hacerlo solo
debemos recordar algo de trigonometría
básica si tenemos una fuerza como ésta
que está actuando con un ángulo theta
con respecto a la horizontal y queremos
descomponerlo en sus componentes
horizontal y vertical si la magnitud de
este lado que es la hipotenusa f
mayúscula entonces la magnitud del lado
adyacente al ángulo recordando su cato
ante trigonometría será igual a la
magnitud de la hipotenusa por el coseno
de este ángulo la magnitud del
componente vertical será igual a la
magnitud de la hipotenusa por el seno de
este ángulo también podemos verlo de
esta forma si el vector está así en
dirección contraria pero con este ángulo
theta ahora los componentes lucen si el
componente vertical tiene la misma
magnitud
su dirección es hacia abajo y el
componente horizontal también tiene la
misma magnitud pero su dirección ahora
es a la izquierda finalmente es la misma
idea si este vector tiene una magnitud f
que corresponde a la hipotenusa de este
triángulo la magnitud del componente
horizontal sigue siendo f coseno de teta
aunque la dirección vaya en sentido
opuesto y la magnitud del componente
vertical sigue siendo f seno de t está
regresando a este escenario el
componente vertical se ve así y el
componente horizontal luce así cuál es
la magnitud del componente horizontal es
la magnitud de la hipotenusa por el
coseno de 60 grados o sea 20 newtons por
coseno de 60 grados es muy útil tanto en
trigonometría como en física conocer los
valores de los senos cosenos y tangentes
de ciertos ángulos comunes como 0 grados
30 grados 45 grados 60 grados y 90
grados
podemos usar una calculadora pero es
útil saber que el coseno de 60 grados es
igual a un medio 20 por un medio es
igual a 10 newtons
si queremos conocer la magnitud del
componente vertical será igual a 20
newtons por el seno de 60 grados y es
útil saber que es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 3 entre 220 entre 2 es 10
por lo que esto es igual a 10 por raíz
cuadrada de 3 newtons ahora si podemos
usar esta información que obtuvimos al
descomponer el vector fuerza en sus
componentes horizontal y vertical para
usarlos en el diagrama de cuerpo libre
ya que ahora tenemos vectores paralelos
o perpendiculares a la superficie y esto
nos permite pensar en qué fuerzas van a
equilibrar estos vectores en el diagrama
de cuerpo libre que ya tenemos vamos a
dibujar un diagrama de cuerpo libre de
este tipo con el bloque la fuerza de
gravedad hacia abajo de 10 newtons es
esta la única fuerza que actúa hacia
abajo no ahora también tenemos el
componente vertical de esta nueva fuerza
que va hacia abajo con una magnitud de
10 raíz de 3 newtons tengan en mente que
no estoy dibujando esto perfectamente a
escala ahora cuál es la fuerza normal
suponiendo que la superficie sigue
y no se comprime de forma alguna
entonces la fuerza normal tiene que
contrarrestar estas otras dos fuerzas la
fuerza normal se verá ahora así su
magnitud es 10 + 10 por raíz cuadrada de
3 newtons que pasa ahora en la dirección
horizontal tenemos este vector que va a
la derecha con una magnitud de 10
newtons ahora podemos apreciar por qué
son tan útiles los diagramas de cuerpo
libre simplemente al ver esto puedo
predecir lo que le ocurre al bloque la
fuerza de arriba equilibra por completo
a las fuerzas que van hacia abajo por lo
que la única fuerza neta que tenemos es
la que va a la derecha con esto podemos
decir que ya que hay una fuerza neta que
va a la derecha este bloque va a moverse
a la derecha nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo